E adesso che fiamma non c'è e siamo soli
in questa sua casa Posso dedicarmi
finalmente alla ricerca di biscotti
torte tutto quello che c'è disponibile
Vi ricordo che erano qui controlliamo
magari troviamo qualcos'altro
Tutti gli attrezzi di fiamma che sono
qui
le sue prove c'è ancora qualcosa di
marcio qua dentro
non riusciamo
sono sicuro che qua dentro ci saranno i
biscotti Ehi oh ma è completamente vuoto
c'è
qualcosa no non c'è niente Ok
continuiamo con la ricerca allora
[Musica]
puzza di piede
Qui
c'è qualcosa che non so che cos'è ma non
è sicuramente da mangiare
e anche qui non c'è niente se non il
quaderno di fiamma
Mmm andiamo una sbirciata magari c'è
qualcosa dentro ingredienti una banana
una banana si parla di cibo allora
vado a prendere Ciao Ragazzi sto
scrivendo qua degli appunti per la
nostra nuovissima agenzia investigativa
se non avete visto gli episodi
precedenti andate subito a vederli dopo
questo video e sto pensando che cosa ci
servirebbe per indagare al meglio in
questa agenzia investigativa forse ci
servirebbe anche qualcun altro per
aiutarci perché al momento ci sono io
che sono modestamente abbastanza brava
nelle investigazioni nelle deduzioni poi
c'è Vitale che si caccia sempre nei guai
ed è bravissimo a mangiare però dai ogni
tanto aiuta anche lui e anche bravo
anche lui in alcuni deduzioni Sempre se
non sta combinando uno dei suoi disastri
e poi non lo so forse ci servirebbe
qualcuno esperto in mostri o non lo so
uno scienziato qualcuno che crei
qualcosa che ci aiuti a difendersi dalle
creature ma soprattutto ancora ci manca
il nome dell'agenzia non abbiamo ancora
il nome dell'agenzia come potrebbe
chiamarsi La nostra agenzia di
investigazione di mestieri e cose
soprannaturale scrivetecelo nei commenti
consigliateci il nome nei commenti e noi
leggeremo tutti i vostri commenti e
Sceglieremo poi il nome dell'agenzia Ma
sbaglio o c'è un po' troppo silenzio che
cosa starà facendo Vitale
ho preso la banana e anche il bicchiere
del frullatore così possiamo iniziare a
frullare questa nuova ricetta partiamo
proprio dal titolo la ricetta
dell'ululato
[Musica]
è una ricetta esotica che non ho mai
sentita prima forse sarà dell'isola di
Honolulu Ma sì sicuramente
Allora ingredienti una banana eccola qui
polline maturato sotto alla luna il
polline maturato sotto la luna lo
troverò sicuramente fuori il fiore più
puzzolente del Prato
Ok Quindi il Fiorente del Prato e il
pollo è maturato sotto la luna li
troviamo fuori andiamo subito in
giardino
[Musica]
Questo sta di sudore di piedi ci stiamo
avvicinando non è proprio il più
puzzolente Ma magari riusciremo a
trovarlo
[Musica]
questo sì che puzza
a giudicare dall'odore sta proprio di
chiappe sarà quello giusto andiamo
Eccoli Questi fiori sono bellissimi e
probabilmente avranno il polline
maturato sotto la luna piena di non so
che cosa Quindi adesso prendiamo il
polline
Perché non esci niente non funziona
sta dando però una strana reazione
io ho voglia di starnutire
[Musica]
sono riuscito a prenderlo un pochettino
Eccolo qua guardate
e adesso che abbiamo il polline andiamo
scappiamo subito dentro a preparare la
ricetta
Sto provando a insegnare a Merlino a
riportare i giochini Vediamo se funziona
e iniziamo con questa palla Rossa
Merlino vieni vieni
non dovevo lanciarla quella ma Merlino
non gliene frega niente Comunque Merlino
Ehi
Ma perché non gliene frega niente è il
Merlino Hai visto la pallina finora non
sta andando per niente bene questo
training Ho un'idea proviamo a lanciare
il frisbee invece Merlino Guarda c'è un
Frisbee non gliene frega un bel niente
ho un'altra idea lanciamo Comunque la
pallina più lontano possibile e vediamo
se Merlino inizierà a rincorrerla pronti
3 2 1
e
dopo
ma perché a Berlino non gliene frega
niente dei giochini è l'unico cane che
non rincorre le palline proviamo in un
altro modo avviciniamoci noi a Berlino
presto
Ehi Merlino guarda quanti giochini che
ho vedi ti va di rincorrerne uno
non capisco Merlino sembra più
interessato a questo coso distrutto che
ha le palline proviamo a lanciargli la
lo stesso Guarda Merlino prendila
ha funzionato
[Musica]
non l'ha presa ah
e anche Circe qua Forse Circe inseguirà
le palline e un po' difficile per lei
riportarle ma vediamo cosa succede Se
lanciamo una pallina cerchio
[Musica]
Brava dirtelo adesso devi solo di
portarvela
[Musica]
RCI sono più interessati al giardino che
alle palline Proviamo con l'ultimo
oggetto che ho il frisbee ma lo
lanceremo da lassù così Volerà in
Altissimo andiamo Siamo in cima alla
montagna possiamo ora lanciare il nostro
premio con un supernaccio
e mi sa che non ho capito bene come si
lancia il frisbee Ok Questa volta devo
perfezionare la tecnica 3 2 1 via
Oh
ho mangiato il frisbee sull'albero ora
come faccio a prenderlo
Oh no lo vedete là sopra Eccoci qua
abbiamo finalmente tutti gli ingredienti
il portone il fiore puzzone la banana
L'aceto di riso che c'era scritto qui
non lo avevo letto Per fortuna che ho
riletto la ricetta è un po' d'acqua
cominciamo proprio dall'acqua quindi La
ricetta dice aggiungere poca poca di
acqua perché perché poi praticamente
Questo si andrà a gonfiare e diventerà
gigante e io non voglio sbagliare il
fiore puzzone dobbiamo stare attenti a
questo perché non indicava bene quanti
metterne mettiamo un paio di petali che
puzza uhm
confermo fa veramente schifo Ma quanti
Quanti bisognava metterle non mi ricordo
Boh guarda io provo a metterlo un po'
tutto Vediamo che cosa succede uh uh
messo tutto così almeno non sbagliamo
L'aceto di riso anche questo poco Uh ho
fatto un po' un casino qua va là che ho
già tagliato prontamente la mettiamo qui
perfetto e adesso ricontrolliamo la
ricetta vediamo che cosa dice allora ci
vuole anche un pelo di cane
Ma c'è anche la variante col pelo di
gatto Sai che ti dico io frullo tutto
adesso e poi aggiungo il pelo di cane
per me è quello con il pelo di gatto lo
faccio assaggiare ad Anita Perfetto
andiamo a frullare Tutto ok Abbiamo
messo tutto qui dentro e adesso è il
momento di frullare pronti E vai
perfetto ricetta pronta i due bicchieri
una variante per me con i peli del cane
e una variante per Anita e qui ci
metterò i peli del gatto Merlino Ciao
Merlino Ciao
Ascoltami
Ciao Ciao Merlino Ciao ciao
vediamo Guarda Ecco i peli di Merlino
dobbiamo Addirittura due Ma sì
abbondiamo e c'è anche Circe Ciao Circe
Ciao
Uh Quanti peli ma non ciccia me ne
servono solo uno due al massimo Ok
ce ne sono tantissimi i peli di Circe in
uno mettiamo i peli di Circe nell'altro
metteremo il piede di Merlino pronti Vai
mescolare per 10 minuti ed è pronto
attenzione pericolosità 8 perfetto e
adesso non ci resta che
mescola 10 minuti
Ok
provo a spostare il ramo magari riesco a
farlo cadere
si sta muovendo
Ho un'idea proviamo con la pala a far
cadere il frisbee vediamo se ci arrivo
[Musica]
Evviva ce l'ho fatta è caduto hai visto
Merlino
[Musica]
Merlino non vuole ridarmi il frisbee lo
sta distruggendo
Grazie Bravo sei pronto sei pronto a
prenderlo 3 2 1 via
e ora Merlino portalo qua dai porca ma
lo sto distruggendo
non ce la faccio più a girare vediamo se
sta succedendo qualcosa
Vabbè per fortuna che la mia gialla
almeno non è così schifosa come questa
Vorrà dire questa io mi preparo quella
gialla Anita ieri Anita
ha un colore un po' Strano però che cosa
ci hai messo dentro e tu non ti
preoccupare Eh praticamente È super
buona cioè della fragola mirtilli rossi
fiori erbe di giardino
[Musica]
E allora tieni Non la voglio più ma no
no no no no no no no non mi interessa
proprio
perché io non ho messo la parte zucchero
Rosa i frutti rossi Tu invece con i
frutti rossi Eh vabbè buonissima non mi
convince poi questa ricetta che hai
preso da fiamma cioè Secondo voi mi devo
fidare devo bere questa sorta di
frullato con questo colore viola quasi
nero ma sì sono i frutti rossi ci sono
tanti mirtilli è per quello che ha preso
quel colore no E allora perché tu non la
stai bevendo Smettila
no no guarda è buonissima
[Musica]
sei Davvero buonissimo
Vediamo se riesce
la tua è un colore ancora più schifo
so Beh adesso tocca a te e va bene
siccome l'hai bevuta tutta la saggio che
io vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è sordato l'hai fatto apposta a fare una
cosa così schifosa
di fiamma e poi guarda io non bevuto
tutta
Vabbè io vado fuori a giocare con
Merlino eh Non mi fare assaggiare più
queste ricette strane ok oh no adesso mi
tocca pulire tutto questo macello
E va bene un gran Peccato Tutto questo
mi sono sporcato
Qui c'è qualcosa
[Musica]
non mi ricordavo di essere così peloso
Vabbè Vorrà dire che dovrò andare
dall'estetista
e adesso questo dove lo metto e non so
ecco
che prurito
Ma questo che cos'è
[Musica]
tutti questi peli devo proprio andare da
un'estetista No la ceretta No purtroppo
ho paura della ceretta non lo voglio
fare no no no no
meritato riposo è vero Circe
ciccio ciccio
Che cos'è questo Aiuto Aiuto c'è
qualcosa che mi segue c'è qualcosa che
mi segue Uh c'è qualcosa di più
[Musica]
forse mi è venuto in mente è stata la
peperonata che ho mangiato ieri che
abbiamo fatto esplodere tutti questi
Poli di peli I pelidi Ma che cosa sta
dicendo è stata la pozione che ho bevuto
prima il frullato che ho bevuto prima
devo assolutamente tenerlo nascosto da
Anita Altrimenti altrimenti sarò fuori
non posso fare questo devo nascondermi
devo nascondermi subito
Che strano dove è finito Vitale È da un
sacco di tempo che non lo vedo Vitale
dove sei non stai mangiando tutto il
cibo che c'è in casa vero o io un modo
per attirare Vitale
un gelato sono sicura che adesso
arriverà Vitale dove sei vitale
[Musica]
Vitale Innanzitutto da dove sei comparso
E perché ti stai coprendo la faccia
[Musica]
questo sole
fastidiosissimo che mi impedisce proprio
di
piacere agli occhi aperti Perciò è
meglio se sto coperto
solo fastidioso e quindi stai
nascondendo qualcosa che cosa hai
combinato
assolutamente niente assolutamente
Fammi vedere
no Mi è venuta un'idea avevi parlato di
gelato Chissà vero Ah ah ah
Vitale sta nascondendo qualcosa cioè
qualcosa di grosso giudicare dal fatto
che non si faceva vedere in faccia è
meglio se vado a spiarlo dalla finestra
andiamo
sono fatta non mi ha visto Anita in più
porca e rimettete un gelato Solo che
adesso devo devo proprio trovare una
soluzione
da questa porta finestra devo riuscire
Anzi riesco sicuramente a spiare Vitale
vediamo che cosa sta nascondendo non
devo farmi vedere però
Non so da dove cominciare
il diario di fiamma
Eccolo qui magari posso trovare la
soluzione qui sicuramente se c'era la
ricetta ci sarà anche la soluzione No
com'è l'antidoto Ah questa ricetta Io lo
spero proprio allora la ricetta è qui
vediamo Ma
dov'è l'antidolo qui sulla ricetta ma
manca l'antidoto ma che sta facendo
dove lo posso trovare fiamma non ho
scritto niente qua E adesso che cosa
faccio formula
pozione non mi dire che quel frullato
che mi ha fatto bere stamattina
Oh no no
sento che quella quella ricetta quella
pozione mi sta per trasformare in lupo
mannaro
Aspetta voglio vedere meglio
[Musica]
ho finito